à noite é uma satisfação enorme estar
aqui no palco do ted
falando um pouco da minha experiência
pra vocês
essa sou eu
aos cinco anos na minha primeira
formatura e esse é o meu primeiro
trabalho onde na cidade onde eu nasci e
vivi no da chamada cidade e um distrito
no interior do município próximo daqui e
eu nasci e vivi lá até os 19 anos 19
anos com a minha família eu trabalhava
nesse mercado que era o maior da cidade
fazia atividades como o caixa e entrega
de mercadoria reposição diversas
atividades e estava numa zona de
conforto tinha é 17 anos morava com os
meus pais vivia uma vida tranquila
tinha até que um salário razoável e
chegou o momento de ir para a faculdade
nesse momento é eu estava com 17 anos e
eu encontrei eu enfrentava todos os dias
quatro horas de viagem ea pra vinha pra
outra cidade onde eu estudava e saía em
torno de cinco horas da tarde voltava
pra casa meia noite e meia era
desafiador era cansativo trabalhava
durante o dia e num momento determinado
os primeiros dias eu lembro de um dia
que eu cheguei em casa e falei pra minha
mãe que eu não ia mais que eu não queria
pra faculdade que aquilo não me
pertencia que eu estava fora daquele
contexto as pessoas eram diferentes de
mim é aquele ambiente não fazia sentido
pra mim e aí a minha mãe me chamou pra
conversar e falou que eu ia assim que
ela tinha um sonho quando ela era
criança quando era menina que ela queria
ser professora
mas que ela não pode estudar porque ela
tinha que trabalhar e cuidar dos irmãos
ela era a menina de casa e ela não tinha
não teve essa opção e ela me disse que
ela não me daria o direito de cobrar
isso dela no futuro que eu estudar sim e
eu não tinha opção de não ir para a
faculdade e eu encarei aquilo é mesmo me
sentindo um pouco peixe fora d'água
estava num ambiente na cidade eu era um
pouco é bichinho do interior falava
diferente das pessoas me sentia um pouco
estranha naquele contexto
mas fiz um esforço pra assim fazer novos
relacionamentos novos contatos conhecer
as pessoas e nesse momento comecei a
perceber novas perspectivas para a minha
vida
comecei a ver e ver que naquele mundo da
cidade naquele ambiente de cidade grande
tinha muitas oportunidades que eu
poderia é encontrar a minha vida tinha
novos aprendizados que eu pude poderia
obter e que se eu realmente valorizasse
aquela oportunidade e abraçasse talvez
eu pudesse é me tornar uma pessoa melhor
ter novos sonhos e vi que o mundo é um
pouco maior do que o mundo que eu vivia
que realmente eu deveria abraçar e ir em
busca de algo maior
então em outubro de 2003
eu encaminhei um currículo para uma
empresa para uma cooperativa numa cidade
próxima daqui também e conseguir um
trabalho e nessa época eu me mudei foi a
um marco da minha independência
eu a minha mudança foi uma mala de
roupas e eu fui de mudança com ônibus da
faculdade sair de casa com 19 anos
e foi em busca dos meus sonhos é nessa
época eu me lembro muito bem
das vezes que eu fui para o mercado por
exemplo e tinha vinte reais para gastar
e com esse dinheiro eu precisava fazer a
compras do mês das coisas que eu
precisava dos meus utensílios e eu
lembrava também da minha mãe dizendo não
deixa o sabonete debaixo do chuveiro
isso custa caro economiza não gasta
tanto o xampu é isso custa caro seu pai
trabalha se sabe quanto ele trabalha
para conquistar e quando eu ela falava
eu pensava mas como chá também é porque
que fica falando essas coisas que que
exagero e não aumentem que eu tive que
tirar do meu bolso e e pagar e sabia de
onde saía eu realmente aprendi a dar
valor para o dinheiro aprendi a dar
valor principalmente pro meu esforço é
não somente por dinheiro mas sim pra
onde saíam aqueles recursos e nessa
época eu aprendi a respeito dos momentos
que nós negligenciamos o valor das
pequenas coisas e também foi assim
sobre a minha bicicleta é eu morava num
apartamento com outras cinco meninas e
nós dividíamos um apartamento tinha não
tinha elevador tinha dois lances de
escada eu ia trabalhar todos os dias de
bicicleta pedalava quatro quilômetros
por dia e me alimentava muito mal porque
também não tinha muita opção de como de
comer fora eu ganhava muito pouco eu
precisava sobreviver com aquilo e eu
deixava minha eu pegava minha bicicleta
subia para o apartamento no final do dia
levava bicicleta comigo e nuno de manhã
quando eu ia trabalhar descia com a
bicicleta uma tarde de verão pedra
horário de verão eu cheguei do trabalho
e deixa bicicleta lá embaixo e
e estava muito cansada fui subir
deitei na minha cama e adormeci
no outro dia de manhã me preparei para o
trabalho desse ea minha bicicleta não
estava mais lá
e nessa época nesse momento eu aprendi
sobre gratidão sobre dar valor para as
coisas que nós temos mesmo as mais
simples coisas que nós temos e muitas
vezes não valorizamos e tinha até um
amigo na faculdade que tirava sarro de
mim e dizia quem é que quis roubar uma
bicicleta azul com o banco laranja
porque ela era azul aqui ela tá lá a
laranja mas ela era azul porque ela
tinha sido reformada e realmente era
feia mas ela era muito importante pra
mim e eu aprendi que nós devemos dar
valor para as coisas que nós temos sim e
aí eu pergunto pra vocês
você já sentiu gratidão hoje pelas
coisas que você tem e em 2005 eu tive um
terceiro momento onde eu sair da minha
zona de conforto é que eu mudei de
trabalho
eu passei eu estava nessa cooperativa
onde eu tinha o meu primeiro emprego
formal minha carteira assinada meu
primeiro registro e eu recebi uma
proposta eu tinha mandado infinitos
currículos para uma cooperativa de
crédito onde eu queria entrar e eu
recebi uma boa proposta de eu entrar lá
como estagiária e eu não pensei duas
vezes em aceitar a oportunidade porque
eu acreditava aqui se eu fizesse um bom
trabalho com certeza eu crescer ia lá e
tinha muito mais oportunidades para
crescer lá e fui deixei a carteira
assinada e fui ser estagiária e eu me
lembro de um dia que eu fui trabalhar
já nesse novo trabalho usando
rasteirinha e uma colega de trabalho que
era uma mulher muito poderosa ela já era
uma gerente tinha uma imagem ótima ela
falou pra mim você tá indo tomar tereré
e no momento que ela falou isso eu sabia
exatamente o que ela queria me dizer
porque às vezes nós negligenciamos a
nossa imagem é porque é por algum motivo
que nós não damos importância pra isso e
eu não estou me referindo não estou
querendo dizer que nós devemos seguir
padrões de beleza impostos muitas vezes
pela sociedade não é isso é realmente
está adequado ao ambiente em que você
quer atuar eu queria crescer na
cooperativa queria ser uma gerente
queria ser alguém de um pouco mais de
status e estava indo trabalhar como uma
menina e nessa época eu passei a mudar a
minha forma ea forma como que eu me
vestia eu me lembro da primeira vez que
usei salto alto e é a primeira vez que
usei maquiagem e os colegas de trabalho
diziam nossa tá diferente está usando
social tão bonita e realmente as pessoas
passaram a me ver com olhos de mais
importância e então eu vejo que eu
aprendi que nós devemos nos adequar aos
aos ambientes onde nós gostaríamos de
atuar e aprende também nessa época a dar
valor para as pessoas e para as pessoas
transformadoras que passam pelas nossas
vidas
aprendi que todas as pessoas que nós
encontramos independente do cargo do
status do conhecimento do nível de
graduação que ela tem pode nos ensinar
alguma coisa e muitas vezes nós não
damos a oportunidade da pessoa
contribuir de alguma forma conosco
eu tive muitas pessoas maravilhosas que
passaram pela minha vida e deixaram de
alguma forma alguma marca algum
aprendizado
e quando nós temos bons relacionamentos
quando nós temos na turquia em contatos
eu conheço eu eu costumo dizer que nós
não precisamos saber de tudo mas nós
precisamos ter pessoas que sabem e assim
a nossa vida fica mais fácil a gente
consegue fazer muito mais coisas
relacionadas ao que nós queremos
desempenhar aos desafios que nós
queremos encontrar então dar valor da
importância para as pessoas é muito
significativo e muito relevante para a
nossa carreira pra nossa história
e aí eu pergunto novamente se você tem
permitido que as pessoas entrem na sua
vida e você tem dado espaço para
aprender com as pessoas com quem você
tem convivido e o quarto momento
importante que eu quero destacar quarto
momento que me fez sair da zona de
conforto e de conforto
foi quando eu conheci o diogo meu marido
hoje eu estava na faculdade ainda e e
foi realmente muito relevante pra mim
porque com ele eu com seu deu um novo
passo que foi à maternidade e se essa
foto do meu primeiro nosso primeiro
filho guilherme e também é em função da
maternidade eu fui levada a fazer uma
outra escolha na minha vida que foi o
quinto momento que eu marquei aqui pra
falar com vocês é eu estava numa cidade
e trabalhava em uma cidade viajava todos
os dias e nós nos casamos eu fui morar
para outra cidade e quando guilherme
nasceu eu não me permitia a eu não
imaginava viajar todos os dias e deixar
ele bebê em um lugar pequeno sozinho
precisava se ele sentia que ele
precisava de mim e talvez muitas
mulheres aqui me entendam que nós temos
muitas vezes que passar por esse tipo de
conflito não é dividir
eu quero ser uma profissional quero ter
uma carreira quero fazer algo diferente
mas eu quero ter uma família eu quero
ser mãe
quero cumprir com o meu papel e nós
somos ficamos com esses com esses
conflitos internos e então nesse momento
eu tive que tomar uma decisão muito
importante e deixar aquele trabalho que
eu tanto amava
com aquela equipe que eu tanto amava e
era incluída participar vá porque eu
escolhi a minha família mas eu dei um
passo também junto a isso e na verdade
eu troquei de trabalho eu encontrei um
outro trabalho que é onde eu estou até
hoje e com isso vieram muitos desafios
foi uma mudança eu já era um neste
momento era uma estranha no ambiente de
trabalho não estava mais na zona de
conforto eu precisava conquistar o meu
espaço conquistar novas pessoas e eu fiz
o que precisava ser feito né conquistei
as pessoas falei é é da minha história e
devagar fui fazendo o que eu precisava
fazer é e aí eu pergunto quantas vezes
tudo o que nós precisamos é apenas
acreditar em nós mesmos
muitas vezes nós deixamos de acreditar e
deixamos de dar um passo importante
porque temos medo eo medo nos limita a
fazer o que nós precisamos o deveríamos
fazer e eu trouxe essa imagem que é
quando eu falo da minha vida
profissional ela demonstra a realização
é a imagem da minha equipe hoje eu
lidera uma equipe de mais de 80 pessoas
e considero realmente que faço parte
desse grupo que eu ajudei a construir
são pessoas maravilhosas uma equipe de
alta performance e que nós somos mais do
que uma equipe de trabalho nós somos uma
família eu faço parte da alta gerência
da cooperativa e sou muito realizada
nesse espaço e ainda assim é nós
precisamos refletir sobre os desafios da
mulher no ambiente corporativo e volta a
falar dos conflitos familiares não é
muitas vezes mesmo as pessoas me
perguntam como é que você dá com
tá de ter filhos eu tenho dois filhos
hoje pedro guilherme
o diogo meu marido traz junto nessa foto
e as pessoas falam como você dá conta de
ter dois filhos você viaja está o tempo
todo pra cá pra lá e tem as crianças o
teu marido não te cobra e eu procuro
dizer que nós precisamos de uma
estrutura para nos ajudar
isso sim é muito importante eu tenho uma
estrutura maravilhosa que me acolhe me
ajuda e nós precisamos ter ao nosso lado
pessoas que nos impulsionam para os
nossos sonhos e não pessoas que nos
segurem e que irão nos prender pra eles
não podemos ser pessoas que nos cobram
não vai não faz ou aí você vai chegar
tarde de novo não vai te faz feliz
vai que quando você voltar eu tô aqui e
isso faz toda a diferença na nossa vida
com certeza
e também devemos nos questionar a
respeito da maternidade se ela realmente
só da mulher no momento que nós tomamos
a decisão de construir uma família
realmente deve ser uma decisão conjunta
porque há talvez vocês que têm algo a
que têm filhos estão aqui me entendam
que realmente a vida da gente muda muito
depois da maternidade mas que não dá pra
querer assumir tudo sozinho é se assim
você que decidir se você quiser ter
alguém do seu lado é importante dividir
essas responsabilidades e por fim eu
gostaria de deixar aqui alguns
aprendizados
pra resumir um pouco do que de tudo o
que eu falei e o primeiro deles é
permitam se descobrir permitam se
descobriu que qual é o seu sonho o que
você quer para a sua vida o que você
busca pra você e tem a gratidão às
pequenas coisas porque a nossa vida
repleta de pequenas pequenos
significados pequenas coisas a quais as
quais nós devemos ser
pratos para sermos mais felizes
valorizem as pessoas e o impacto que
elas podem ter em nossas vidas porque
com certeza toda pessoa que passa pela
nossa vida pode agregar algum
conhecimento e algum tipo de aprendizado
vivam tudo que existe fora da zona de
conforto porque é lá que está a mudança
e o sucesso não esperem que o sucesso
venha bater na sua porta sai da zona de
conforto e vai em busca do seu sonho
acreditem em si mesmos e principalmente
lembre se de que tudo que precisamos
está dentro de nós muito obrigada
[Aplausos]